welcome to this video playing five trick
I am five check the ruie let's see got
the main line coming no playing with d3
playing it and playing it simple there
are there are other ways to go about it
with Bishop c5 or our stuff with g6 but
keeping it within the normal within the
normal um types of setup okay 92 no egos
a fork or claim mmm not many ways to go
shouldn't go Bishop be seven after a
four Bishop on b7 is mostly looking at a
well-protected pawn on e4 so normally
you shouldn't play Bishop d7 if white
itself already played d3 okay so let's
see many many ways to play maybe here i
can try for this rupee aid bishop f8 a
regrouping also night a5 and c5 was as
possible yeah the the closed way leave
some much room for varying your you play
your setups for both sides really
so I have a neat regrouping here maybe
even g6 Bishop g7 later but in general
it is a nice small improvement that 45
z5 a bit and just AM improves my
position slightly okay i can go hmm i
could also let's do that many ideas I
can also get the night to g6 and a
different form of regrouping aha
interesting interesting move hmm yeah
why not why not
and how do I continue here interesting
maybe Bishop e6 is also an idea hmm
yes Queen f3 Aquino 3f Bishop g4 cases
this is not yet not yet a problem okay
i'm unsure unsure what to do maybe you
can play a 40m hmm yeah but it should
reform Bishop g4 and then we should be
three it it does not help him very much
Bishop g5 has also would be very nice to
get in but not really apparent how I how
I can do it the ship is on f8 so okay so
but maybe I can just keep it simple and
get this get this Bishop traded upon
coming to your six this also help in
terms of covering their five square
I guess you should take I cannot really
believe that retreating us any good I
mean I can even play or consider to play
d5 if he know he's really should take
and now again he's threatening boo boo
show page six I guess yeah he is knight
c6 can take b5 take a tech h6 not good
yeah I know it looks awkward but still
I'm threatening g5 winning a piece
didn't really didn't really see another
move another move an alternative move
let's say
g5 is a threat he's taking quite some
time here so I'm not quite sure what
what you do maybe this is not really a
really leading luck too much for him
yeah I still thought okay I can go here
and then again I'm threatening and
threatening g5 still on the threat nice
move but if I go g5 isn't it still
trapped can maybe you can sacrifice
takes takes nine age five fighters
should should should just a number of
checks i guess i can go he can go to a
three of course i'm not really i'm not
really winning material here okay hmm
edge for this g4
I'm not quite sure how I should continue
Oh by this I didn't didn't think about
at all and it is it is interesting at
least check check it's got a ton of
checks check just you put check
check if you had no way to avoid a draw
and you can tell when we play on game
drive yeah okay well I don't think I
should avoid the draw because of the
position i guess but i didn't i didn't
see the move at all and i can play I can
play something like this which which is
also equal probably we were all we were
very much we had a relatively equal
position I but ok I encompass giving
white-coated distinct edge after Queen
f3 I don't I didn't didn't suspect that
night h5 in fact and here what's so
great here for watch a g4 Wow g-form ok
yeah this is make some sense that it
also gives why the possible square on g2
for the age 49 hmm yeah okay this is
better for what I didn't see this idea
at all g4 looks looks good job I don't
really have a have any active idea here
hmm Wow after this is still there's g4
but he didn't he didn't have that idea
at all just like me at all so right here
we are in this about equal position here
I rook g8 I could have been look g 8 ah
this is stupid oh whoops
and here i think i should be much better
now i get no I get the piece without him
allowing a perpetual war stupid stuff
yeah okay Josh here I Jack I'm not sure
he could have played on certainly 97 I
mean okay he didn't have any time but
position wise this is probably probably
good for wide sorry here here he's got
the three pawns why does just better him
but he didn't have any time so it took
the practical decision to force the draw
okay tough game thanks for watching